so I hear there's a new Mars rover
currently in planning on track for a
launch next fall the news is that the
rover will be about the size of a small
SUV which is good to hear I have nothing
but the utmost respect for Spirit and
Opportunity in the three years that
they've been chugging along on the
surface of another freaking planet I've
gone through three laptops that means
that either they're incredibly well
built or I am harsher than the
inhospitable waste of the Martian
landscape or both however I do think
it's time we established a real American
presence on Mars and I can't think of a
better way to do that than with an
interplanetary SUV it also gives me hope
that someday we will get back to that
planet and colonize it because wherever
you find big honking trucks you'll find
Americans as long as we're still in the
production stages I have a couple
suggestions first the name spirit
opportunity we're naming our spacecraft
like they're Montessori kids I think the
new Mars rover needs a name that
captures the true essence of exploration
and scientific inquiry the Thunder space
planet trampler second let's talk speed
the current Mars rovers move at an
average speed of one centimeter per
second Barry White's hands could have
explored Mars's secret places faster
than that I think we should get
something with some power under the hood
I want a Mars rover that can pop
wheelies do donuts maybe jump something
chasm Gulch okay we also need a way for
the rover to take pictures of itself we
get these great photos of the Martian
landscape but I'm getting a little tired
of artists recreations of the actual
vehicle so maybe you can have a little
hatch in the back a little smaller Mars
rover comes out comes to the front takes
a picture or you can give it a big
extending arm so that could take
pictures of itself like on facebook next
william daniels voice the guy who played
kit on Knight Rider we found water
Michael it appears to be coming from
that abandoned warehouse
now that we're presenting a properly
badass profile to Mars let's talk
scientific instrumentation as i
understand it Spirit and Opportunity
have little diggy scrapie things to get
under the Martian surface but as my
aromatherapist tells me there ain't no
better way to dig than with a big-ass
Splosion tell me NASA couldn't get
funding for these low things up on Mars
mission heck I'm willing to donate 20
bucks to the cause right now also a tiny
device that plants a drink umbrella
every 2 yards wherever the rover goes
there's a trail of brightly colored
cocktail umbrellas yeah you like that
Christo you're not the only one who can
put things places finally when Spirit
and Opportunity reach the end of their
useful life when their little power
systems start to fail the new Mars rover
should put them out of their misery just
running a motor it's the only kind thing
to do and there should be video
you